they're targeting hoodies in Oklahoma
and arcade game prizes in Florida but
you'll find January 2015's many of the
month in Dubuque Iowa one of the latest
cities to ban sledding poor kids
everyone's browbeating them to go burn
some calories and then grown-ups go and
ban one of winters most beloved outdoor
offerings we have all kinds of parks at
Hills on them says three where Dubuque
sleezer services manager we can't manage
the risk at all of those places so
what's the plan then have cops patrol
the bunny slopes ticket tiny scofflaws
and their parents a good look enforcing
the sliding bands all you killjoys
across land omaha passes slutting ban
then reversed it because everyone
ignored it turns out you can ban sliding
we can't ban the desire to slow Dubuque
will allow some sledding spots to stay
open but resident Justin McCarthy says
that may actually make sledding more
dangerous for his daughter and other
kids crowding everybody in a 50,000
person town on the two hills is going to
be more of a liability you're going to
crowd him up there's more of a chance
for people to actually get hurt to look
more pressing than preventing injuries
is preventing lawsuits and City Hall
scolds are egged on by parents or slow
to take responsibility for their kids
but quick to sue cities in kudos to
justin mccarthy he's organizing a
protest against frivolous lawsuits and
sledding bands following in the month on
twitter submit your nanny nominees and
check back next month for more examples
of busybodies minding your own business